hey everyone its ears register nurse are
en comm and in this video I'm going to
be going over how to assess the neck
specifically the carotid artery and
looking at those neck vessels now this
is typically done during the cardiac
part whenever you're assessing a patient
either from head to toe or you're just
wanting to do a cardiac focus assessment
and this is really important on those
middle-aged or older adults who have a
history of cardiac disease because what
we're going to be doing whenever we're
doing this assessment we are going to
auscultate the carotid for brewery's
which I'll go over that here in a second
and we're going to palpate and we're
going to fill on the carotid artery we
want to know how the contour feels or
the amplitude and we're going to grade
it and then next we're going to assess
those neck vessels for any bulging
looking for fluid overload things like
that so let's get started so first what
we're going to do is we're going to
auscultate the carotid artery and what
we're listening for are breweries and
that's what I talked about beginning the
video and this is where you have a
turbulence of blood flow and it will
sound like a blowing or swishing sound
and this is indicated of atherosclerosis
narrowing and what you want to do is you
want to use the bell of your stethoscope
and we're going to listen in three
different places to get a really good
assessment we're going to listen at the
angle of the jaw so find the jaw we're
going to go right below it so we're
going to go in there and then we're
going to go mid cervical area which your
cervical areas your neck and we're just
going to go in the middle of it so we're
going to go about right there and then
we're going to go at the base of the
neck and the key whenever you're doing
this is you want to press lightly with
the Bell of your stethoscope and
whenever you're doing that you're just
pressing lightly because you don't want
to create a false bruit or compromised
circulation by narrowing the arteries
and what you want to do whenever you do
this you want to have the patient take a
breath and have them exhale and hold it
for a second while you're listening so
you're not hearing breath sounds and it
won't mess with the sounds that you're
hearing so we're going to listen real
fast
okay so first let's go at the angle of
the jaw okay take a breath for me and
exhale I take a breath for me and exhale
again okay again
okay and that sounded great and then
you're just going to compare sides and
repeat on the other side now let's
palpate the carotid artery now whenever
you're doing this you want to again
compare sides like how you are whenever
you're listening but what you're going
to do is you're going to palpate lightly
and what you want to use is your index
finger and your middle finger finger do
not use your thumb and avoid putting too
much pressure on the carotid sinus which
is up in this area because this has
sensitive baroreceptors and especially
in the older patients you're elderly
patients you cause an vagal stimulation
which will slow the heart rate down so
do not do that it's generally good to
palpate in the lower half of the neck to
avoid that carotid sinus area and what
you want to do is you want to locate the
trachea and the sternocleidomastoid
muscle and in that middle of that groove
is where you will find that carotid
artery and what you're looking for what
you're actually feeling for is the
amplitude and the contour you want it to
feel smooth and rapid have a rapid
upstroke and a slower down stroke and
you want to grade it and a normal
grading is two plus if it's really hard
and bounding it would be three or four
and if it's you can barely feel it it's
diminished okay now what we're going to
do is we are going to assess the vessels
in the neck and we're particularly
paying attention to those jugular veins
and we're looking for increased central
venous pressure and to do that what
we're going to do is have the patient
lay back supine on their back at a 45
degree angle and sometimes it helps to
get an extra little light so you can
shine it on the neck so you can see the
vessels very good and what we're going
to do first we're going to look for the
sterno mastoid muscle which runs right
here and we're looking for the external
jugular which overlays this muscle and
normally what you will see is that it's
slightly flat again you might need your
light or you may not even see anything
at all which is okay and if you do see
that this is bulging or very very large
this is usually present in patients with
congestive heart failure who have
increased central venous pressure but
here it's not
some flat and you want it to look like
that
okay so that is how you assess the neck
for your head-to-toe assessment now be
sure to check out my other nursing
assessment videos a link should be
popping up so you can access that and
thank you so much for watching